hey I'm Issa Rae and I'm gonna teach you
how to not be that guy the best way to
ask me out is to just be straightforward
I don't want hey do you want to go out
for coffee hey do you want to go out for
dinner because this industry is so like
people do that all the time so I need to
know clearly what you mean like I've
been tricking today actually a lot
because I thought it was business and
then it wasn't and that gets
uncomfortable you gotta be like oh I
want to take you out on a date or else
i'ma show up in sweats and a backpack
I've always wanted a pick-up line but no
one's ever given me an original one it
would absolutely work if someone used a
pick-up line on me like I love to laugh
and if it's funny you're you're in there
guys use more original pick-up lines you
could get it I love when men know how to
dress like if you're originally your
clothes if you have a specific style
like I I love that
so I guess we're something that you need
to you just put an effort wardrobe red
flags are dirty shoes wrinkled shirts I
couldn't put in any effort like you
could your jeans you don't have to iron
them but don't make them be all wrinkled
don't make them be all worn stains on
your shirt like we're going clouds
fingernails like dirty fingernails oh I
love a good Cologne I say Cologne can
make you second-guess the man's
unattractiveness you might be like oh
he's that mmm he's gonna fine you know
that's what cologne can do the chef
diesel sparingly I personally like
movies for Thursday I've been recently
advised against it and my brothers are
like no never takes across the movies
don't stop I like being a son
and I need to know if you're the type to
talk in a movie or decide to pay
attention I need to know if you can
carry a conversation about what we just
saw let's look at Ted movies are just a
great test of etiquette like are you
gonna buy me snacks did you buy the
ticket are you gonna offer me snacks and
then yeah you can't be like aren't you
love you think you want to share popcorn
I think that's great I've always done it
share popcorn I feel like that's
intimate but don't like lick your
fingers and put it back we just met
whatever that brought like a sandwich
every bag if a guy found a sandwich on
the first date lucky respect but I
wouldn't we wouldn't go back out again
that's like date three we know each
other we're cool but don't do that on a
first date I looked at what the first
date kiss if the chemistry is right the
chemistry is right you ain't got to keep
it tight I do expect a guy to pay for
everything I want you to pay for my [ __ ]
I still believe in chivalry and I feel
like that's the chivalrous ass if you're
strapped for cash just be clear like
that's just my baby clear apart if a guy
lets me know that he's broke I respect
the honesty I'm gonna have questions
like are you ambitious you feel like
you're gonna get out of broke down I
just need to know these things upfront
but at this stage don't think I can deal
with broke
it's kind of hard to decide like what a
guy should call but I do think a text is
great within 12 hours you got to send it
I had a good time text if you're filling
in and then if you don't send anything
within 24 hours then it didn't go well
that means you weren't thinking about
those things
I'm guilty of it but I feel extremely
disrespecting what it happens to me and
I'm one of those people that was stuck
and I will find out I will find you I'll
find her cousins up on your cave I find
your grandma I'll find oh like track you
down I can get it to the third date
world is interesting to me I just go by
how I feel like I don't put a number I
mean what my girlfriend's this is just
like no always third day always and I
was like girl you can't like like even
just by nature you can't do that but
she's just committed to that and thinks
it's weird if you have a third day like
sex is on the table I'm not I don't
think I really hope you take my advice I
really hope it gives you all the
strength you need to close
don't don't listen to me I don't know
anything so good luck obviously don't
come for me if this doesn't work for you
but it should
you